hey 42 here do you ever look down at
your favorite snack and think how did we
get here in just a few thousand years
we've gone from hunting mammoths to
arguing over pizza toppings take
something like a cheeseburger that seems
like a pretty simple thing right but
think about everything that needed to
happen in order for you to destroy your
waistline with bovine deliciousness we
needed to make the bread that rises
domesticate cattle extract sugar for the
ketchup and this is before we even get
on to the cheese who worked out that
squeezing the cow's nipples and letting
it go moldy will turn out to be one of
the greatest joys in the universe let's
be honest food is weird so let's look at
six things that completely changed how
we obviously the first major step was
when we learned how to control fire
despite what raw food and fusee outs may
tell you cooking is vital to our
development as a species the chemical
changes that it creates enable us to
absorb a far higher amount of useful
energy which is how we were able to make
the evolutionary jump so having such
gigantic brains which gobble energy even
if you're just sitting there staring at
the wall you know like Friday nights to
give you some examples the body absorbs
about 30 percent more energy from cooked
oats and wheat than when they're raw
under whopping 78% more from a cooked
egg compared to raw eggs so maybe stop
drinking mayonnaise and just have a fry
up instead you know like a normal person
the process of cooking including things
like chopping and grinding as well as
heating means your digestive system does
far less work to extract energy since
you've already broken down the meat
connective tissues or soften the plant
cell walls
you're basically outsourcing that work
so the little people inside you can take
a bit of a break and finally have that
meeting about what that weird lump is on
your shoulder after meat one of the
oldest cooked foods is bread the process
of combining flour and yeast may seem an
unlikely discovery but yeast actually
grows naturally on cereal grain nut is
left out so it was one of those happy
accidents like when someone dropped a
pig in maple syrup and bacon pancakes
vented the next major discovery was
learning how to make food last longer
because chasing mammoths and foraging
for berries every day was tiring and we
suspected that TV would be invented soon
and we didn't want to be too busy
chasing deer to be able to watch it
there are numerous ways to preserve food
and different climates gave rise to
different techniques the main aim of
preservation is to kill microbes and to
prevent them from having the moisture
they need to multiply in hot climates
discs um be done through drying but it
wasn't so easy for us dump people far
from the equator those in more moderate
climates turn to salting their food to
preserve it instead osmosis is where the
water inside a cell tries to reach the
same concentration as the water outside
the cell so when you salt to meet the
moisture outside the cells has more
salts than the moisture inside the cells
so the water is drawn out through the
semipermeable cell wall to try and
balance it out it's a bit like communism
but with less furry hats and more water
other methods of preservation include
smoking sugaring pickling jellying or
just hiding your food somewhere where
all the microbes can't find it with the
rise of electricity the refrigerator
became an everyday item for almost every
household the great thing about a fridge
is like you get the benefit of
longer-lasting food throughout having to
dramatically alter its flavor or texture
which most preservation techniques often
do it also enabled us to plan ahead
rather than having to constantly buy
things we needed that day Scottish
physician William Cullen is considered
the founding father of the fridge since
he gave the first recorded demonstration
of artificial refrigeration back in 1756
the modern fridge works by pumping a
coolant for a series of evaporator and
condenser coils soon we will embrace a
futuristic power of the smart fridge
where you will be able to text your
device on your way home to see if you're
out of milk and it'll probably start
hiding the cheese if it thinks you put a
few pounds on you're not the boss of me
fridge one of the most reliable and
long-lasting ways to preserve food is
with canning an invention that largely
came about thanks to a game that the
world likes to play
a cold war humans love war we play it
all the time but it does make lunch
rather complicated when you've covered
all your veg in mustard gas and blown
the legs off your chef Frenchman Nicolas
Appert when a substantial 12,000 franc
prize for developing a way of sealing
food in glass jars to help the troops in
the Napoleonic Wars canning slowly
developed from here although the led
they used to solder the cans didn't do
people much good but it was about a
hundred years later when World War one
started that it really took off
unfortunately there weren't enough tins
to keep the Brits happy and by 1917
British soldiers were issued with
cigarettes in done Fetterman to try to
suppress their appetite both world wars
had a major effect on food especially in
Britain since we imported a large
percentage of our produce rationing
during World War two greatly reduced the
availability of a lot of products so
much so that many children thought that
fruit such as the banana were fairytale
inventions that didn't actually exist
since they had never actually seen one
rationing went on until 1954 in the UK
and this is largely how the British
ended up with such a poor culinary
reputation around the world the food was
incredibly boring because there weren't
many options and it took us a long while
to get out of the habit next up is not a
technique but the one man who has had
the biggest influence on food all around
the world is Auguste Escoffier his book
legee kalenna published in 1903 broke
down the methods and techniques that
make up all classical cookery it formed
the basis of classical chef training to
this day in 1890 ASCO fier moved to
London to take into all of the kitchens
at the Savoy Hotel his system of
organizing the kitchen had a huge impact
on their safety and on the consistency
of the food by breaking the cooking
process into sections each chef became
part of a team who oversaw only a few
small parts of the meal enabling them to
perfect it and repeat it before ASCO
fier it had all been a bit hectic and
you'd be lucky to get a sandwich about
someone
popping off a finger and getting hair in
the butter dining at the Savoy became
hugely popular and was what started
London's restaurant culture since before
this our ristic rat ik families would
have their very own chefs and eaten
their own grand houses but with the draw
of great cooks hotels began to get
crowds of excited diners and so the
fine-dining restaurants came after
without Escoffier the emperor chefs
there'd be no long Klum no Gordon Ramsay
are no cheeky nandos when your tummy is
rumbling and you scroll through all the
things that you could possibly eat in
your head Pizza tacos ramen a kebab a
curry sushi you soon realized that the
one thing that affects what we eat today
more than anything else is immigration
there has certainly been a long history
of ingredients being discovered and
included in national cuisines just look
at potatoes sugar rice but it is the
people who bring the rich history of the
food and the new ways of preparing it
that really increases a country's eating
vocabulary the Italians gave New York a
lot of its famed cuisine and try taking
a Californian to a Mexican restaurant
outside of their own State you'll get
more tutting than at a political debate
curry is now one of Great Britain's
leading national dishes and the famous
chicken tikka masala one of Britain's
most eaten dishes with something
invented here as part of the influence
of immigrants but it's not actually an
Indian dish so who knows what exciting
new dishes will be invented in the next
ten years back to the power of shared
knowledge food preparation has been
rather basic up until now it's only in
recent years that we started
experimenting with how technology can
shape our food from Suvi to Sparrow
fication
perhaps in the future we'll be able to
grow perfect steaks in jars and splice
wheat DNA with a deep fat fryer so we
can grow donuts in our own garden
well one can dream at least thanks for
the view subscribe for more 42 why is a
1.2 square kilometre island called Hans
Island and kind of do in Denmark just
can't help but put their sticky hands
all over there really is up
lately nothing going on in there
scientists have discovered that the
beloved koala BIR may be the least
intelligent mammal on the planet